joining me this week is an author of
futurist in the 2016 presidential
candidate for the transhumanist party
aiming to put science health and
technology at the forefront of American
politics Zoltan is man
welcome to the Reuben award thank you so
much for having me the transhumanist
party sounds very philip k dick Tom
Cruise kind of futuristic movie Minority
Report something something what is the
transhumanist party well you know
transhumanism it's really the field of
kind of using science and technology to
modify the human being but it's all
sorts of crazy technologies but it's
been around for about thirty years but
there's never been a political element
to it and so about two years ago I
founded the transhumanist party now we
have a bunch of advisers and nominated
to run for you know the presidential
election in 2016 and all sudden it's
become a little bit of a hit and now we
have people worldwide that are very
interested in it and we're putting forth
a political foot to support
transhumanism and radical science yeah
all right so we're going to talk some
radical science let's start with the
radical science that is in your left
hand right now there is a chip in there
right you are part cyborg yes there's a
tiny chip in here it's literally the
size of a grain of rice it's so small
you inject you can self inject it with a
syringe and it allows you to do things
like start your car or in my case I have
a door opener where I just put my hand
to this little screen and it opens up
automatically and it also actually if
you have the right software it sends out
a text that says win in 2016 if I come
close enough to your your phone really
if there's all sorts of funny little
things so what is the element of that
that connects you then to politics like
why say all right I mean I'm into this
stuff and we're going to get into all
the AI stuff and genetics and all that
kind of stuff but what makes you say all
right I'm interested in this why go the
political route at the same time well
you know we have a lot of scientists we
have a lot of Engineers millions of them
they're doing amazing work but
scientists and
many technologists are not oftentimes
the most vocal when it comes to politics
and yet if you don't pass certain types
of regulations you can't practice the
science I mean we have an endless amount
of debate right now about the CRISPR
genetic editing technology about whether
we should regulate the field of
artificial intelligence
well most scientists and technologists
are not stepping up to voice their
opinions or sending lobbyists to
Washington so that's really what my
campaign is about and what the
transhumanist party is trying to do
we're trying to be you know that first
organization that puts its foot in
Washington DC and says hey pay attention
to science and technology we represent
that so basically you're trying to just
make that leap so they're scientists
just doing their thing for the good of
science or for whatever company they
work for or think-tank or whatever it is
but they're doing it sort of like just
separate from the way our public policy
is made and you're trying to link it
then back to the way policy is created
yeah I mean I'm not a scientist I'm a
you know study philosophy in college I'm
someone who's trying to popularize these
ideas of science and technology because
I love it I just really I'm just
fascinated with these fields and I find
that the voice of many scientists is
usually in you know they're in the
laboratory with their in their white
coats bent over doing their experiments
and I think they need somebody to be out
there in Washington saying how can we
get you more either money from the
government or create less regulatory
kind of hurdles so you can do your
experiments and in the end you know
everybody all of humanity all Society is
going to benefit from more science and
more technology yeah so as someone
that's into Science and Technology which
usually has a little something to do
with facts and reason and things like
that you can't be that thrilled with our
political climate at the moment no no
I'm not thrilled with it you know I mean
and you know not to to kind of bash
religion or anything like that but you
know one of the main things of my
candidacy is that I'm running as a
non-religious candidate and we
officially have 535 members of Congress
eight Supreme Court justices and the
president who all believe in a deity and
believe in an afterlife and they're not
that interested in reason they're not
that interested in the science that
leads you know to kind of Bionic hearts
that can make us live indefinitely in
those kinds of things they'll all want
those things they'll want those a lot
like drumming the table and saying let's
put funding for these scientists and
engineers out there and I think if we
could convince them to be you know less
I guess conservative less religious more
open-minded about the future maybe the
government could really actually lead
when it comes to some of these amazing
technologies and these are technology
it's going to make everybody across the
country it doesn't matter if it's rich
or poor live better so that's really
what I'm trying to do is you know drum
up support so that the politicians
across the country you know and our
resources of America will go much more
into Science and Technology yeah and
when we talk about these technologies
whether we're talking about the chip
that's going to start your car open your
garage or whether we're talking about
you know just designer babies or any of
that stuff this is stuff that's going to
happen no matter what the politicians do
so in a way you're trying to just give a
road map so that once this stuff comes
around we have the sort of basic
firewalls to make sure we're dealing
with them properly is that yeah yeah I'm
in fact one of the funny things about my
Candace ease I'm not totally like Pro
sites like let's do it all for example I
don't believe that we should let
artificial intelligence develop
completely unregulated it's it's very
dangerous to think we might have a
machine that's as smart as a human being
and far smarter than us here in 10 or 20
years so in some cases my campaign says
take a step back but whatever we do we
want to ask those questions and you know
it's you're going to find that most the
major politicians like Trump or Clinton
are just not talking about artificial
intelligence even though I've worked
with the US Navy they had it for US Navy
officers in my house a few months ago
I've been consulting with them and we
all know that artificial intelligence in
the military is sort of the most
important 10-year window of what you can
do in terms of national security
um whoever can get to AI first it's
going to have such an unprecedented
advantage in you know hacking codes in
rewriting software and these kinds of
things things where you could actually
literally like you know change the
global landscape overnight if you were
the very first person you know very
first a country for example imagine from
North Korea got AI first and was able to
hack into all our systems
our electricity stop our power stop stop
the water flowing and stuff like that
and then you know the cleaners I mean
you could you could turn off America
this is the big problem and so you know
the US Navy and I had been discussing
this saying well of course this is a
number-one priority of national security
moving forward the next 10 years yeah so
is that the only way to get government
to respond to some of this stuff
properly like you have to show them a
problem that is so bent that's so
connected to national security more than
anything else that they go all right
well we got to get on AI it's not just
something that we can have some guy with
the robot you know climbing stairs look
at wait for because this is this is big
stuff you know the answer sadly might be
yes that you do need a national security
issue it's not just oh that's fun you go
have fun with your robots or your chips
in your hand you know actually the real
reason the the US Navy would we even got
in touch in the first place was they
knew that because when I got my chip
implanted on I was on a campaign trail
and it was kind of quite a bit of
publicity about that you know being the
first chip presidential candidate and
they you know they called me and said so
we have a problem we have navy personnel
new soldiers essentially you know coming
on to both military bases and nuclear
armed vessels and they have civilian
chips in their hands that they've done
how do we deal with that we don't know
if we want to let you know a you know a
guess a navy person onto a submarine if
he has a civilian ship and that
submarine has nuclear capabilities we
don't know enough about that technology
in his bodies and you know meaning we
don't know if they have malicious intent
or someone hacks into it then can
exactly in that and that's the real
issue at hand is that so they're
actually now creating a bunch of and
this is what their reports were about
there they're trying to create policy
saying whether you can or you can go on
to these bases with this kind of
embedded technology and you know the
funny thing about my chip is I've had
about a year now but it's basically
already obsolete like I can't pay with
my chip
but in the new chips that are coming out
right now you're able to go to Starbucks
and swipe your hand and pay with that
and that's just in one year so in three
or four years can you imagine what these
chips are going to do they're going to
like I can have all
works of crazy things that they're going
to do for us you might be able to talk
through them like you a cellphone and
you know that presents a huge amount of
problems for I guess all sorts of
authorities including just you know
flying on an airplane and going through
screening right so you mentioned that
you're not for sort of unfettered
scientific pursuit because of what you
said about AI for example that it could
lead to some terrible stuff but is there
any way to actually control that I mean
once technology and once science has
gotten to a certain point is there you
know even with the best intentions that
somebody's going to come in and go no
I'm going to do the thing that is going
to lead to the robots taking over or
whatever the case may be uh unfortunate
I just nobody has discovered that yet
it's part of the reason that it you know
AI remains an unregulated industry is
that nobody knows really how to regulate
it
you really unless just by stopping it
completely and then you know that makes
that's crazy what are you gonna do tell
a university you you can't study this
stuff so that's been one of the the main
issues with the AI industry now I don't
I actually don't want to you know
necessarily stop it in any way I would
love to have AI I just um I think I
worry like everybody else that the very
first AI is going to be at least as
important and big as the Manhattan
Project you have to see AI in terms of
almost like a nuclear weapon it could be
so smart that it can do all sorts of
things and it could be malicious and it
could be very nice so you know whatever
happens it's one of the very few times
that I sort of I don't want to say that
I become anti transhumanist but I do
pull back and say you know some of the
experts that have been saying you know
LM us and whatnot have been warning
they're correct to warn that this is
this is something we've never done
before we've never introduced a species
on planet Earth that's smarter than us
and we need to be careful with that
would you say that's just the next step
in human evolution like the whole point
is we evolved to get to the point where
we could now create something smarter
than us and we are just sort of going to
accelerate what evolution is at while at
the same time putting chips in our
bodies and and creating some other
things some humanoid type thing yeah you
know and I think if I did this interview
with you in 25 years probably 20 30 % of
me would already
machine parts or completely synthetic
and I have friends right now who are
about a year maybe two years away from
amputating a limb and putting on a
robotic limb the robotic limbs that tie
into your neural system now have gotten
so sophisticated that you can grab a
glass of water you can you know you can
write with them and in they be doing
this by right choice or because yes
that's the whole thing they be doing it
electively yeah so you know if it's one
thing if you've lost your arm because
you were in a war zone and you know a
landmine or something like that but
there are biohacker transhumanists out
there young kids mostly that really want
to take it to the next level and they're
also trying to implant you know chips
onto their brains and so that they could
be the very first people to commune with
basic artificial intelligence so they
have the first telepathic communication
with machines because we now have so
much different types of brain wave
headsets and brain wave technology that
you can actually put a chip in your head
and talk to your computer in a very
basic it's the beginning of the matrix
right this is what some of these bio
hackers are starting to it's it's it's
it's a part of the transhumanist
community but it's sort of the the real
aggressive kind of young young crowd and
I totally support I think it's wonderful
stuff but the arm one is very important
because I actually would like an
artificial arm to I mean eventually
probably in 10 or 15 years you can be
able to take a football and throw it a
mile mm-hmm so I mean there's going to
be advantages at some point about this
the question is you know how will you're
a family member deal with it how would
my wife deal with it just like well if
it's some robotic metal arm I don't like
it you know but it might be a warm
synthetic arm that looks very similar to
what flesh is and still be able to throw
a football a mile long so we're going
there and I've been 25 years I might
have something like that yeah so let's
back up for a second and just talk about
what got you personally involved in this
what's your background and what made you
say all right I'm going to start a
political party and talk about some
stuff that nobody's talking about on the
on the political front sure well you
know I'm formerly with the National
Geographic Channel I work there as a
journalist for about almost four years
well over four years and I did a lot of
reporting with a video camera solo
reports three to four minutes long
in between their new show called
National Geographic today and the the
reason it's important is I covered a
huge amount of stories in the short
amount of time where I kind of really
got a good picture of the world but a
lot of young journalists actually start
off in conflict zones and so a lot of
the coverage I did was in conflict zones
so I saw some pretty heavy stuff deaths
multiple rape victims I saw torture
victims and it really got me worried
about dying and you know for any of the
viewers who don't know at transhumanism
main goal is trying to overcome death
with science and technology so the more
tragedy that I saw the more I got
interested in using technology and
science to to stop death and I guess the
war zones really hit it in to me I had a
very close incident with a landmine in
Vietnam when I was covering a story
there and afterwards I just said you
know I'm kind of done being a journalist
or at least such things I came home I
wrote my novel the transhumance wager
the book did really well I combined it
with my journals and skills and I've you
know started writing a lot about the
movement which sort of led me to being a
more visible figure in it and you know
that kind of led to the transhumance
party and also this ability to I guess
suppose you know run for the presidency
because a lot of it is media interaction
and I've been an on-camera guy for a
long time so it's been very helpful to
to take that so that's sort of from you
know ten years back to I guess where we
are today yeah
so it kind of seems to me that for a for
a full party what you would need is
people like you that are into the
technology front then you would need
some ethicists some legal people
probably a series of things that I'm not
thinking of at the moment do you have
that core group of people that you kind
of use to say this is the idea but now I
need different people to look at it from
their own particular place of expertise
we do we have an amazing advisory board
but I just to be honest I don't actually
consult with them that regularly because
frankly they're they're all pretty
important and people and I can't bother
them to us but certainly you know I have
consulted with each of them at various
points to get you know a bigger picture
on how to best run a campaign and
also how to how to grow the movement you
know the transhumance party in this time
its main aim is not to you know it's
hard to define what a political party is
to begin with because you know there are
hundreds of political parties in America
right now and when you start one it
takes years I mean the Libertarian Party
took them 40 years to get on all 50
state ballots so we're here two years
into this you know political party well
we will talk about that in just we're
really just trying to grow the movement
itself yeah and hopefully by 2020 maybe
the transhumance party would then be
recognized enough where we have enough
state parties cuz we have a couple state
parties but not enough right now to make
a real dent in the kind of political way
we want it's a it's a growth process and
it takes time yeah so you are conceding
defeat for 2016 yes yes and in fact I
have said that a very beginning fact
that I I was never running to win
because that they it's really impossible
to win the presidency I mean you have to
be on all the state ballots and then you
have to actually win these states and
even if you're somebody really really
popular the chances of actually
overturning the you know the the
Republican the Democrat system is is
very difficult what you can do is spread
a message and the way media works these
days is you can really grow moving we
see transhumanism like environmentalism
was 20 years ago we think you know
environmentalism today has three or four
billion people everybody you know a lot
of people consider themselves green we
hope transhumanism does the same thing
and so we're trying to create a roadmap
to that kind of success yeah so with
that in mind you auditioned is that the
right word to be Gary Johnson's VP is
there an audition what would you what do
you call it
you know um they say come in and
audition that's around for us what do
they say it was an interview yeah Gary
was very early in on his you know
declared his intent to run for the
presidency and somebody introduced me to
him I was at the time interested I've
you know I've always been running my
novel the Transformus wagers broadly
considered a libertarian book and I
would say that I'm a left libertarian
and so I was what does that mean a
libertarian means somebody who's sort of
on the border between being a
Democrat and being a libertarian right
on the edge and that's where I fall
because I don't fall and I know
libertarians say oh well you can't be
libertarian unless you're a full
libertarian come on I mean there's
there's gray zones to it are you for
driver's licenses this is my big one
with the libertarians when they're
screaming about no licenses and it's
like guys if that's what you're fighting
about
yeah then this is never going to be real
no I am absolutely for driver's license
yes I I find like you just got to be
realistic because after all you can't
just jump in there and expect to change
the world unless you're going to also
compromise a bit so I try to compromise
quite a bit more but you know I'm Gary
Johnson invited me to spend the you know
be a guest at his house in New Mexico it
was just him I you know I spent the
night I interviewed with him he made me
dinner
we watched orphan black together he
actually introduced me to yeah so that
was great because he hadn't been
introduced to orphan black but he also
introduced me to house of cards which I
had never actually seen I have two kids
so I don't have a TV at home and so I've
been watching those addictively now and
then the next morning we continued our
conversation and you know I don't think
he told me upfront that you don't have
much of you probably don't have much of
a shot because I'll probably able to get
a you know a governor of some sort but
I'm interested in in what you represent
because you're young and you have a
millennial crowd and you're all you know
I think Gary's very interested in
science and technology so for me it was
a it was an honor to you know to
literally talk to him for 16 18 hours
over you know time and you know he
picked my brain I picked his brain and
you know I became a big fan of his to be
honest and and but I didn't get the job
I wish I had yes I had I won't ask if
you guys smoked pot but you can just not
appropriately no comment fair enough
it's interesting you mentioned orphan
black because have you seen black mirror
by any chance which was also on Netflix
you know I've seen only one so black
mirror I've mentioned it on the show a
couple times really all about how we're
all I don't have my phone on me now they
took it away from me but that we're all
walking around with this device and that
it's becoming a mirror to us of our
lives and what I love about it is that
it's it's showing the future in only
three or four years how subtle changes
will actually change us
how much you think just the phone and
the technology the power that we're all
walking around with is changing us
without us even realizing it I think
it's dramatic I think for example even
this election cycle I've never no-one's
seen such hate no-one's seen such
trolling I think that's a direct result
of our ability to be 24 hours a day
connected we've never been so connected
because of the the phones it's because
the devices we're becoming a nation of
sort of haters and trolls because we
have more content hitting our brains
we've ever had before and that may or
may not be good um I think these are the
kinds of changes that are happening just
you see in the real life you need to
make a Hollywood you know a film on it
so I think it's very important but one
of the one of the most striking stories
I think of the last few years that's
really hit me is uber everybody was so
excited they had a new chance to have an
uber career as you know driver is a an
uber driver and you could make money
doing that and now all son uber like
literally within a couple years now
interesting driverless yes so that
entire career that was so made so many
young people excited is almost now gone
yeah and that's how quickly the
acceleration of technology is happening
these days nobody realizes that what
happened in ten years is going to happen
in the next five years that amount of
change yeah but then after five years
it's 2.5 years then it's one point you
know one and a quarter it so you go out
ten years and you're literally making up
four or five times the amount of change
that's happened in the last decade we
are not prepared for it it's going to be
super exciting we're going to stumble a
lot as the society
you